leipziger auwald achte april 2020
frühling lockdown viele spaziergänger
auch miriam eine junge mutter ist
mittags mit dem hund unterwegs trägt ihr
baby am körper
ein mann greift sie an schlägt mehrmals
mit einem hammer auf sie ein
ich saß hier im home office ist wie so
viele leute und dann erschien so eine
schlagzeile auf meinem bildschirm
schweres verbrechen im leipziger auwald
und der leipziger auwald ist von hier
ungefähr 1 kilometer entfernt
miriam stirbt das baby überlebt die
polizei gibt bekannt
tatverdächtig ist der ex-freund
jede vierte frau in deutschland erlebt
mindestens einmal im leben körperliche
oder sexuelle gewalt durch den eigenen
partner
und dann tauchten halt hier in
stadtviertel dieser ganzen graffiti auf
und überall bin ich auf diesen begriff
bezieht gestoßen ich kannte das
irgendwie hatte ich das schon mal gehört
aus südamerika da gab es diese riesigen
demos und ich musste auch in mexiko
werden ganz viele frauen getötet und
danach hat das passiert ja nicht in
deutschland das hat nichts mit
deutschland zu tun so ein trugschluss
wie die journalistinnen caroline hunters
und julia koschitz nach eineinhalb
jahren recherche wissen das phänomen
verzieht noch nicht in der gesellschaft
angekommen die politik will nicht mal
den begriff offizielle anerkennung in
den bundestag hat er es dennoch
geschafft chemie zieht ist die tötung
einer frau in einem geschlechts
bezogenen kontext dass entscheidungen
die er in einem zusammenhang mit der
abwertung und unterdrückung von frauen
stehen
2009 10 gab es 117 fini ziele in
deutschland 2020 waren es 139
dabei erfasst diese statistik nur
partnerschafts tötungen das heißt jeden
dritten tag tötet ein mann seine
partnerin oder ex partnerin fast jeden
tag findet eine versuchte tötung statt
die häufigsten fehmi ziele sind
sogenannte trennungs tötungen
und er kommt damit nicht zurecht und
versucht dann sie umzubringen und drückt
damit eine form des besitzanspruch es
aus er will über sie und ihr leben
bestimmt er gesteht ihr nicht zu dass
sie das selber tun kann und dann reden
wir von einem prinzip meistens vergeht
nach der trennung und gewissen zeitraum
meistens vier wochen bis ein halbes jahr
dass es so mit der gefährlichste zeit
raum und da passieren diese tagen der
leipziger überfall am hellichten tag
eine initialzündung
proschwitz und tanzes treffen
überlebende angehörige
anwältinnen
in ihrem buch für mit side beleuchten
sie die oft unsichtbaren strukturen
sexistischer gewalt
zeigen der gefährlichste ort für frauen
ist ihr zuhause
quer durch alle sozialen schichten und
kulturellen hintergründe
was ich erlebe im gewicht ist das die
vorstufe nämlich die
geschlechtsspezifische gewalt nicht
wirklich ernst genommen wird das nicht
ernst genommen wird dass sie tödlich
sein kann wie lange das passieren kann
eben dass jemand seine partnerin oder
andere frauen schlägt misshandelt
verfolgt beleidigt bedroht und nicht
wirklich interveniert wird das ist ein
strukturelles problem
gerichte politik medien verharmlosen
vermieter oft als tragische einzelfälle
beziehungsdrama oder gar tat aus liebe
mittlerweile gehen die ermittler aber
von einer beziehungstat aus bei einem
familiendrama im münsterland soll der
vater am morgen noch einer bekannten
erzählt haben dass er plane die ganze
vierköpfige familie zu töten
viele getötete frauen suchen vorher
hilfe bei behörden während die besser
vernetzt und über fimi typische
warnzeichen informiert wäre fast ein
drittel der taten vermeidbar
aber immer alles nur individuell
betrachtet wird werden diese taten nicht
verhindern sie hat das klassische muster
erlebt anfangs ist ja ehemann liebevoll
sie zu ihm nach deutschland ist abhängig
isoliert er beginnt sie zu misshandeln
geschrei wenn ich ihm widersprach wurde
er gewalttätig
sie flieht mit ihren kindern ins
frauenhaus
er stockt und bedroht sie
ich sagte ihm dass ich die scheidung
will er antwortete von mir trennt sich
niemand er sagte auch immer wieder du
bist nichts ohne deine kinder
trotzdem bekommt er das umgangsrecht mit
den kindern bei uns ist immer noch so
dass sie maximal eingesteht es muss
unbedingt umgang stattfinden und die
gewalt gegen die frauen er rückt dann
eher in den hintergrund oder man spricht
von sogenannten auswahl verschulden ist
sie ja ein bisschen selber schuld dass
sie sich so einen mann gesucht hat um
die frau zu bestrafen werden in einem
fünftel der fälle die kinder getötet wie
bei ihr ihr mann erstickt beide kinder
sprüht ihnen bauschaum in den rachen
versucht auch sie zu töten er wird wegen
mordes verurteilt
die verantwortlichen müssen frauen
besser zuhören und sie besser schützen
seit 2008 zehn ist die sogenannte
istanbul konvention zum schutz von
frauen bundesrecht sie regelt dass
chemie ziele im familiären umfeld härter
bestraft werden müssen als tötungen
durch unbekannter beurteilt wird anders
die trennung gilt sogar als
strafmildernd
wenn die trennung vom topf a ausgeht und
der angeklagte durch die tat sich dessen
überhaupt fühlt was er eigentlich nicht
verlieren will entfallen die
mordmerkmale
ist das wirklich auf einmal
nachvollziehbarer weil die trennung von
der frau ausgeht ich denke nicht ich
denke eine frau sollte in deutschland
genau das recht haben sich erst an
beziehungen zu lösen die ihnen man punkt
mehr geld mehr aufklärung durch
anerkennung von fehmi ziethen als
strukturelles problem wäre nötig doch
genau das lehnte die bundesregierung im
juni ab hoffnung gibt es trotzdem es
gibt ein heer von
ganz tollen engagierten menschen die
sich darum kümmern polizistinnen
wissenschaftler/innen
sozialarbeiterinnen die genau wissen was
es braucht und ich hoffe dass diese
leute einfach mehr gehört werden
in leipzig läuft der prozess um die
tötung von miriam noch der angeklagte
schweigt der öffentliche druck gewalt
gegen frauen konsequenter zu bekämpfen
wird dagegen immer lauter